[Applause]
yes yo real talk
jk rowling looked trans bruh i think
that's why she hates
trans people so much all feelings no
facts this is all feelings no facts
she's
i feel like i should get more money
that's literally how he negotiates
i want more no okay you're racist
okay but for real though so this this
popped up on twitter and i was like
i they call her transphobic all the time
like you know okay whatever
and i start reading the no that's why
this girl don't like trans people
because she looked too much like them
bro this is the article right so
titled troubled blood the storyline
centers around a cisgender
male serial killer who dresses up like a
woman to murder his
female victim why she giving ideas
though like
loki first of all she's given serial
killers ideas
and if you dress up as transgender
there's going to be a bunch of woke ass
white women
that are going to just go home with you
so they don't seem transphobic
and then they're gonna end up murdered
that's a fact
sometimes it pays to be a little bit
prejudiced bro
she said that it's like nah that's that
uh patrice rest in peace the goat
remember that patrice bit he goes uh he
goes
uh what do you say if i walk on a plane
and i see a black pilot
i'ma be like are you driving this plane
to where the white pilot is
i'd rather be at home
out of breath feeling a little bit
racist
for running away from some dangerous
looking people than
lying in a pool of my own blood feeling
open-minded yeah
and literally that is a lot how people
act though yeah be honest like when it's
life or death
yeah you do i had that girl that i had
said she couldn't be my um
skydiving instructor mm-hmm
what what i didn't tell you all this
story i don't remember
i was supposed to go skydiving with mtv
and they gave me some girl that was like
5'3
and she was like yeah you're strapped to
me and then you're going to do the whole
thing and i was like
it's not going to be you so it's guys
yeah they cause a problem the mtv people
are upset i'm like you ain't jumping out
the [ __ ] plank
yeah i need a grown man to jump out the
plane yo
hey yo bro i need a grown man straps to
my back
wait so what did you think you think she
wouldn't be strong enough to pull the
cord
what that's a one job that actually
might be better if she's small that's
like
that she's the best i'm not taking no
chances bro what if i start spinning she
don't got enough weight to stop the
spinning
she's a pair of shoes she's just holding
on to your back i'll take it work like
that i don't know how it works but my
life was on the line and i didn't want
this little
girl on my back [ __ ] cutie this girl
was fresh out of cuties
my life is on the line she's 5 feet 200
pounds
i need a grown-ass man wrapped around me
you're not holding me around my waist
you know like [ __ ] jack and the
diamond [ __ ] from titanic i don't
remember her name what's her name
titanic listen i'm having some blunders
right now myself
can i blunder bruh
i would never let you be my skydiving
instructor
never once you do have guns but it's too
dangerous bro
it's too dangerous but how dangerous is
scott having though you never heard of
anyone dying skydiving
what yes you do no you never hear that
[ __ ] yes
yes you do you hear about the people
that are flying in the [ __ ]
little squirrel shoots or whatever
that's not about what did you just say
yeah i don't know what you said i don't
understand squirrel suit came out as
well
shoots yeah you describing akash is big
no but yeah maybe you don't hear that
many stories because they try to keep
that marketing down yeah
they don't want to put those stories out
because then we won't go hundreds how
many people die
one out of ten how many between one and
ten
like more than ten every ten jumps how
many people die
zero every ten jumps but you know what
market only takes one jump
yeah i'm saying let's be honest here you
could die any single way
it's not real real talk i went to this
place and uh sorry to blow him up 516
skydive
everything was fine a week later the guy
who jumped with me
died from his shoot not open it up alone
yeah you're doing some dumb [ __ ] no he
wasn't doing some dumb [ __ ] it's one
thing to do
that how do you do that some dumb [ __ ]
he didn't do it on time
yeah he waited until he hit the ground
yeah
that is dumb you think he forgot ah yeah
no i'm not doing that [ __ ] i'm not
playing around when it's life or death
we are not playing around
i'm not skydiving but if i was better be
a big ass dude
you gotta skydive with men bruh you
gotta scott haven't met you also need to
have a male
urologist
i'm not letting no female doctor look
inside my dick tell me what a dick
should be or not that's actually a good
point i wouldn't want a male
gynecologist if i was a woman
why come on yo you don't know nothing
about this
do you have a female [ __ ]
gynecologist taylor do you have a
you have a female kind of creep just
looking at [ __ ] all day sick
my girl's dad's a gynecologist but i
agree
they keep it it is what it is bro that's
the worst job when you think about it
because you're just looking at [ __ ]
when they're all [ __ ] up yeah you get
tired of it probably
when you go to the gynecologist you
don't go right after you wax
it doesn't matter you don't go right
after you wax you don't go when it's in
perfect situation you go in your
vagina's itching or burning that
actually might be better though
when do you go when you're [ __ ] looking
like pumpernickel bread
if you're looking at vaginas every day
from nine to five you probably go home
you're tired of that [ __ ] you're tired
looking [ __ ]
you gotta look at your wife's [ __ ] you
don't want none of that and he's so
grateful
why is he grateful because he's like wow
it doesn't have [ __ ] jelly beans or
whatever
say that word again try to say that word
again and in the middle
please don't eat fritos okay
you are so high why are you acting like
you're not high
yes you are we have a certain standard
of professionalism
really i didn't appreciate that taylor
yeah that crowd i thought your buddy was
in the room right there bro
that's not why you go to the guy in
colleges all the time just when the
[ __ ] is [ __ ] up that's not why you
have to go
when would you go to the gynecologist
when your pussy's not [ __ ] up when you
need that smear
um that peppy yeah just like
a checkup everything's cool i'm just
saying you're looking at it all day
the sick or not i don't want to look at
[ __ ] all day and have sex with my wife
at home i don't try to take my work home
with me like that that's a good point
got [ __ ] at work
you don't think they get propositioned
all right that's a good question
they've been gynecologists to get
propositions bro well you think a female
urologist gets proposition
if if a female urologist we don't go to
that that job don't exist
there's a urologist you ever been to one
guys don't check up on our dick
check it up on my dick half of my dick
got to be green before i go check up on
my dick
a urologist appointment no guys i've
made that alex in his leg before he goes
real talk how [ __ ] up would your dick
have to be before you go to the
urologist
you can't even imagine it i'd have to
wake up and have no dick
i have to wake up with no dick and i'll
call the urologist and i'd be like bruh
help me find it help me find it you got
it you got a dick over there brother
you have to have a dick over there
dick's laying right here
dick my dick disappeared in the middle
of the night bro you can't even wait too
you have breakfast and [ __ ]
i would have breakfast before i even do
it hell yeah
i'm not gonna do that [ __ ] first thing
in the morning okay if i if
i'm telling you going to the urologist
is a rare thing that we do not do as men
yeah you're right we don't care about
our health in general
yeah but we double will not let people
just touch our dicks
we don't even touch our own dicks after
we pee who does we don't
we don't who does we don't pat it dry we
don't pat it dry but we give it a whack
we get that chariot moving
sometimes you've got a yaw you ever say
that urine on freak people out in russia
russia i'd be at the airport i'll just
go yeah
why i don't know i just [ __ ] with people
this is what it is anyway point is jk
rowling looks like a trans
and um do you think she's still the goat
she's full on transphobia
no i don't think she's transphobic but i
think she's being like radicalized the
book is wild bro the book is wild i
think this is what happens like
when we were talking about this earlier
it's like when
when you when you have an opinion that
actually is reasonable her opinion
wasn't crazy she had a reasonable
opinion and when you are
chastised and ripped apart for that
opinion publicly like actor hermione
and [ __ ] harry from the show
criticized she made
them [ __ ] multi-millionaires
right this [ __ ] was already a
millionaire she didn't need them she
didn't need the movies
the books millions she fought to have an
all-english cast like
you could have easily just been some
[ __ ] american dude harry daniel ralph
what's his name
i mean she she made a great deal when
you think about it like
the way that she said i'm saying she
really did so
the point is she had the ability
to do whatever the [ __ ] she want she
gets criticized for this opinion about
being transphobic
okay she gets pushed into a corner and
all of a sudden
loses and this happens to a lot of
people they lose all empathy for the
other side
yeah before she's trying to make
intellectual arguments and like really
trying to like
showcase something reasonable and she
was basically saying the experience of a
woman is different than the experience
of a trans woman
yeah right trans woman doesn't have a
period of trying to not going through
puberty like a woman's going through
she's there is a fundamental difference
and they just tore her apart
yeah right harry potter out here
i'm disappointed i'm just i'm sorry my
dick disappointed
i hate disappointment [ __ ] you who the
[ __ ] you would be disappointed in me
yeah
kind of [ __ ] is that you not my father
yeah you know what i mean i'm
disappointed in you i don't give a [ __ ]
she looked like she could be his father
if anyone should be disappointed jacob
rowland should be andrew yeah for
getting sick on that goddamn ride this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] made me almost throw up
yeah
and she's stupid a caricature of him in
the movie and that's racist
she did do that who would the gringott
yep the gringotts also dobby
turns out a lot of the ugly characters
that look like trolls and gremlins look
like me
wow that's a little bit disrespectful
she's schulzophobic
she is short of phobic she's afraid of
this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you should be disappointed i'm
disappointed at her
i'm disappointed in her that's some
haughty [ __ ] to say
what is this before we move on
what does hardy mean
that [ __ ] was crazy what you just said
like we were supposed to know what that
country ass word meant
party that's some hardy [ __ ] to say
that's a hardy ass [ __ ] in it this
is the hardest she the really the
hardiest brother the heartiest [ __ ] in
hogwarts
yeah daniel radcliffs matt hardy
avita kadabra [ __ ] we don't need you
but in all seriousness she just loses
all empathy for the other side now she's
doubling down and trying to like
and it is a little bit [ __ ] up because
i think loki she's trying to be like be
afraid of trans people
right like what is the character in the
movie
yeah she's like hey beware they're
dangerous they could kill you
when in reality it's probably the exact
opposite i think there's probably more
people killing trans people for being
trans
than trans people running around killing
women yeah yeah
a lot you realize if she wrote a book
about that everybody would say she's
pandering she's full of [ __ ]
this is the only it's the only move
she's gonna read the books let's be
honest
approaching double down she doubles
this [ __ ] got us spinning bro